for years viewers have turned to this
hit reality series for their fix of
sweet bikes and family fights but if you
lost track of the American Chopper stars
during their long hiatus don't worry
we've got you covered with this look at
everything they've been up to just a day
before the American Chopper reboot
premiered in March 2018 Paul senior
filed for bankruptcy
according to paperwork obtained by page
six Tuttle admitted to owing nearly 50
creditors a total of more than 1 million
dollars against the net worth of around
one point eight million dollars total
also claimed a monthly income of $15,000
and expenditures of just over twelve
thousand six hundred dollars not enough
to pay off his crushing debts my goal
was to you know just build maybe 510
bikes a year more for the hobby and
passion than for making money but the
story wasn't over in April 2000 nineteen
the trustee in charge of tunnels case
asked the court to dismiss the
bankruptcy petition according to that
filing Tuttle didn't provide the trustee
with a copy of a federal income tax
return or transcript for 2017 and 2018
and more proof that his financial
situation quote indicates a negative
cashflow four months before he filed for
bankruptcy and the whole world suddenly
knew about its daunting financial
problems Paul senior produces enormous
Montgomery New York estate on the market
for 2.9 million dollars total then cut
the price to two point four nine million
dollars and by early 2019 it was down to
just one point six five million the
trustee in charge of his bankruptcy case
said Tuttle seemed sure that selling his
home would solve all his money woes but
it doesn't seem to have worked out that
way at least not yet all those fights
between senior and junior were
apparently real tensions ran so high at
Orange County Choppers that in 2008 Paul
senior fire junior from the shop even
though he co-owned it junior later told
Fox News that his dad giving him the ax
was what he called a big favor because
it set him on the path to starting his
own business Paul jr. Designs opened in
2010 the beauty of it is is you can get
a history lesson and you can see all
these bikes you've watched us build on
the show for
years Paul senior then tried to legally
force jr. to sell him his 20% share of
their company but it turned out that
getting rid of jr. represented a breach
of contract with the Discovery Channel
and could have led to the show's
cancellation this all led the network to
launch the spin-off American Chopper
senior versus jr. after that series
wrapped in 2012 jr. went back to Paul
jr. designs then in 2015
celebrated the birth of his first child
a son named Hudson American Chopper fans
came for the bikes but stayed for the
fights but fabricator and mechanic
Vinnie DiMartino tried to keep his head
down and get to work in 2007 he left the
chopper franchise and founded his own
shop V Force Kustoms he wrote on the
company's now-defunct
site I had gone as far as I could there
I really didn't have any chance for
advancement and I had always wanted to
have my own shop so the natural
progression was to leave and start my
own place everybody thinks I'm a
die-hard biker I'm really not in 2013
DiMartino abandoned bikes for cars and
open DiMartino Motorsports a car and
truck repair company in Walden New York
Rick Petko seemed like an even keel guy
on American Chopper even when the two
tunnels split up to run separate shops
Petco stayed on with senior but stayed
amiable with jr. both tunnels attended
his wedding in 2012 and by the end of
2015 Petco is a dad to two girls he was
still working at Orange County Choppers
by that but tired of his 90 minute
commute each way from his home in
Pennsylvania to the shop in New York he
took a job as the chief fabricator at
the Pocono Mountains harley-davidson
complex in Pennsylvania roughly a mile
from his house and torn these bikes that
are you know hundred years old even
though he's redoing on you you're adding
history to him it's a something cool
matter when he's not working with metal
Petco still works with metal he runs a
small knife forging company out of his
home called our PD & Company fall senior
and junior frequently disagreed but
fortunately there was a third member of
the tunnel family around to maintain the
peace Mikey Tuttle
but he walked away from the chopper
franchise in 2012 saying I want to seek
some peace of mind and work on my
relationship with my dad
he later came back to work but Tuttle
used part of his time off to open an art
gallery in Montgomery New York which
featured his paintings it closed in 2014
but Tuttle pursued another artistic
project a web series talking healed
right here on television launched in
2016
bumming around aims to shine a light on
New York City's homeless problem check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]